sur ce chantier à maurepas ont construit
une toute nouvelle résidence étudiante
vendredi dernier on posait la première
pierre en coulant dans le béton ce
parchemin où est inscrit le nom de jan
palach car cette résidence portera le
nom de cet étudiant tchécoslovaque qui
s'est immolé par le feu en 1969 pour
protester contre l'invasion soviétique
un symbole de liberté destinées aux
futurs locataires d'un point de vue plus
terre à terre ses 183 studio permettront
de combler un manque dans le département
c'est pour redynamiser la ville c'est
aussi pour permettre à des étudiants de
la ville et de la périphérie de se loger
c'est pour répondre aussi à un besoin
qui régional vous savez qu'il manque
plus de 10000
logement étudiant en ile-de-france dans
l'humour pas voulu s'inscrire dans cette
démarche et répondent à ce besoin
côté pratique les étudiants seront
situés à cinq minutes du centre et de la
gare de la verrière 100 places de
parking seront également créés très
proche de la nationale 10 la résidence
devrait profiter d'un traitement
acoustique pour le bruit le bâtiment se
veut respectueux de l'environnement avec
par exemple des panneaux solaires pour
les besoins en eau chaude
en tout trois mille huit cents mètres
carrés dont une laverie un local vélo et
un espace commun et les constructeurs
ont pensé à une évolution à long terme
du bâtiment les logements étudiants ont
c'est un besoin instantanée et donc de
ce fait même en espérant que ce soit
conservé ainsi c'est quelque chose qui
doit pour être amené à évoluer
différemment par la suite en fonction
utilisation différente
l'aspect initial de l'opération les
cloisons sont utilisés à cette fin là
pour pouvoir ajuster les logements les
agrandir permettre un agrandissement
pour des logements de plus confortable
le soin étudiants étant assez réduit les
cloisons entre les chambres pourront
donc être abattus pour créer des
logements plus grands pour des personnes
âgées ou des familles monoparentales une
possibilité pour le futur mais pour les
années à venir
le bâtiment sera bien réservé aux
étudiants ils sont attendus à la rentrée